Doctor has prescribed a CT scan of the abdominal area for my husband. We know that the test
involves sub-radiation. Are there precautions to take before after such a test to reduce the
negative effects? Thank you so much. So yes, a CT scan produces a lot of radiation. So out of all the,
you know, what are called, plain film x-rays or, you know, just a regular x-ray if you went through a
chiropractor, got an x-ray of your cervical spine. The most, the highest dose x-rays was called
the chest x-ray because you leave the, the way it's set on the x-ray machine, you use more radiation.
So always, you always measure the dosage, the rad dose of radiation that you're getting from
something based upon a chest x-ray because that was how they originally measured this. So yeah,
CT scan is like getting 50 chest x-rays. So that's a lot of x-ray. So that's a lot of radiation that
your body has to deal with. So what do you do? What do you do with all that radiation? Well,
your body has to get rid of it. Just like you have to get rid of, you know, you know,
damaging effects of oxidative stress. So that's exactly what radiation is. It creates
seractive oxygen species in your body and you have to help get rid of it. So I always recommend
people that are doing CT scan or a PET scan because that's radiation too. To use radiation
holiopaths, you could see it on our store. There's another holiopath made by professional health
products called RadiAlgent. I think it is. RadiAlgent. So I think if you just type in at our store
radiation, you'll see those two holiopaths that you can take. And I just go through the whole
bottle of it to follow the holiopathic. Follow it on the bottle as far as I can take it.
That could be really helpful with dealing with radiation, radiation toxicity.